we're both from the Boston area this is
true yes we both actually come from
towns practically right next to each
other in Boston mmm out you were Newton
um broke lines that's right those are
some tough towns folks and anyway I like
that they believe that and the only
through the toughest Jewish
neighborhoods only 95 percent of people
there go down to medical school
only 95 percent but the difference is
the difference is you have moved out we
both moved out to California to only you
went and bought a ranch you have a ranch
here in California something I would
never even think about doing I don't
know why I just don't think I'm a ranch
guy what do you do as a Boston guy on
that ranch oh gosh all kinds of stuff we
have a motocross track we ride motocross
bikes we hike camp fish all naked you
have a bulldozer now I heard about this
I heard that you have your own bulldozer
and I'd like well used I bought it used
the things are expensive yeah you buddy
that showed a lot of common sense you
didn't go out and get a brand-new
bulldozer yeah no use
you got a used bulldoze there MC Hammer
bought his new yeah he got me big
trouble he bought all five of them new
yeah so you have a bulldozer we actually
have a picture of you on your with your
bulldozer that is a real bulldozer that
thing is serious it's even got the thing
in the back I don't even know what that
does the three claws those are those are
called rippers so if the ground is hard
you can't really push the dirt when it's
hard so you just push those down in on
the ground and they're there probably
three and a half feet long and then you
just push them down on the ground and
start driving and it makes them that's
okay
okay here's my question Matt what are
you doing with this bulldozer are you
building things are you are you doing a
lot of agricultural work well I bought
it initially to groom the motocross
track and we use it to build the
motocross track and my friends that are
you know
why's there in that area than me said
don't get one too big you know and me
I'm like no no it's gonna be big
gotta get a big bulldozer right right
it's gonna be big right oh it's got
better you big than too small right so I
got it that's what I've always said
knowing exactly what you've seen me yeah
you know what I'm talking about don't
know what you're talking about you know
what I'm talking about he knows exactly
if I'm not talking about all right all
right so anyway it's it's turned out to
be what are you doing with it now you're
not building anything with it no I mean
you know you grew because when you ride
on the track that gets kind of chewed up
and stuff so use it to redo the jump
phases and stuff but then you kind of go
knock some [ __ ] down I knew that's what
you do is alcohol ever involved it has a
cup holder so when picturing you having
to maybe a couple of beers god knows
what and then just knocking stuff down
on your ranch yeah it's like Spicoli
Zozo it's pretty that's fantastic so you
get you a lot of fun you should come out
you could drive it it's really fun
they're the real limitations that are on
air in front of an audience invitation
there's a difference you know : you
should come by then later on I call you
from right outside the ranch hey Matt
it's me Colonel Brian I click really I'd
come by can I Drive the bulldozer yeah
really it's a little intimidating but
I'll show you how to do
that's nothing like a dare I could
handle a bulldozer I mean you get a
climb wait well you're tall you probably
step right in I have these crazy long
legs I could get up with one step I'm
ten feet tall
yeah that's pretty impressive I would
love to come by and knock some [ __ ] down
touch it you're Archer that's so cool
have you ever taken it on the highway
that's what I would do I would take it
on the highway
I'd start crushing other cars that would
be fun we'll get something like $50 junk
cars and we'll put them out they would
just crash smash them up would be fun
I'm there I would do that Andy you would
like this show Oh fantastic yeah the
only thing it was in the car
[Laughter]
try and get out you start in the car
then you got to get out before me and
Matt roll over you all right we'll have
had a lot of drinks and you'll be tied
up it'll be hard to get loose time with
me I mean my kids I've always wanted my
kids to have someone really rich to sue
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you